The solution of the previous quiz
said that we had to define
the wide detail fragment layout
in two places:
the layout-land
and the layout-sw600dp folder.
To avoid having
multiple copies of this file,
we should use layout aliasing.
We can check the documentation
for layout aliases
to see an example.
Saw we have a main layout file
that's for one pane UI.
In the layout-large
and layout-sw600dp folders,
we want a multi-pane layout.
In case you're wondering,
layout-large
is for backward compatibilty
purposes for large devices
prior to Android 3.2.
That's when the SW qualifiers
were introduced.
So back to the point.
To avoid code duplication,
we can define the two pane layout
in the base layout folder.
Then, in the values-large
and values-sw600dp folders,
we can create a reference
so that the main layout
actually maps to the two pane layout.
In the Java code, you can
reference it as r.layout.main,
but it's actually referencing
the two pane layout.
This is what the detail fragment
should look like afterwards.
And this is what the phone
landscape view looks like.
If you rotate the device,
the phone portrait view
should be different.
In the next coding task,
we're going to make
the today list item
look more like the other items
in the list for the tablet.